do we really need to weigh cucumber
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by golden
ratio and we'll be reviewing fellow
canadian and fitness and lifestyle
youtuber will tennyson but first let me
tell you about my sponsor golden ratio
so as you guys know i am passionate
about my coffee
and despite the fact that i have a very
sensitive tummy and that can generally
mean that my morning ritual doesn't
always agree with me i literally
cannot give it up so i was very excited
to try golden ratio's monash certified
coffee so this is an alternative to
coffee that is five times less acidic
and it has the essential caffeine that
we love and we need
but without the bitter taste of coffee
so even though i normally feel like i
need like a lot of milk or some cream in
my coffee to make it palatable for me i
actually find that i can drink golden
ratio completely black or i guess i
should say
gold i love gold
so these come in little pouches that you
steep kind of like tea so it's really
easy to prepare without any equipment
and because it's actually gold in color
it doesn't stain your teeth so if you
want to give golden ratio a try check
out my link in the description for 15
off of your order now before we get into
it feel free to pause the screen or look
at the description to check out my
disclaimer including a trigger warning
to those with current or previous
experiences with disordered eating and
if you are new here please do not forget
to subscribe and ring that little bell
so that you never miss out on an episode
okay so if you don't know will he's a
canadian fitness influencer and actually
he lives quite close to me and we know a
lot of the same folks here in the gta in
the industry so he does a lot of fitness
challenges and he shares his workouts
and his diet regimens and in this video
he's sharing his new cutting diet to
lose some fat and build back some muscle
after a summer of traveling so let's
jump into what will eat in a day my diet
has changed dramatically so i have
reduced the amount of artificial
sweeteners i'm eating and focusing a lot
more on whole foods you know i'm kind of
done chasing the feeling of you know
just wanting to feel super super full
and i'd rather actually feel good as
well i love this sentiment i definitely
think that with age and time you start
to gather a bit more data on how certain
foods make you feel
so it is interesting and telling to me
that willis found that he feels better
consuming fewer artificially sweetened
foods now as i've discussed in my video
on artificial sweeteners here
the long-standing assumption that
sweeteners cause cancer
has been thoroughly debunked so you do
not have to worry about that
but for a lot of folks with sensitive
guts
certain sweeteners or consuming
sweeteners in excess
can be triggering especially things like
sugar alcohols and sucralose aka splenda
so if will is feeling better by cutting
those out or really cutting back on
those
then i think that's a really great
choice we are gonna wake and shake with
a smoothie and some eggs what you're
drinking your calories yes but this
smoothie makes me feel good it energizes
me it keeps me full actually and this is
why i have it every single day put it
onto your scale
one cup of coconut water
40 grams of some celery one apple one
full lime some spinach frozen pineapple
blend it up and on the side make some
scrambled eggs
[Music]
and the reason why it's regular in my
diets because it keeps you regular you
want to keep the calories down
of course do egg whites is definitely
the smarter way to go
i just like them and i feel really good
on whole eggs okay so this looks really
amazing
and i love that willa has switched
himself from egg whites only which of
course are lower in calories to the full
egg which includes the yolk if they make
him feel better and he also finds them
more delicious
so egg yolks have been long demonized in
the health community but actually the
latest research combining a prospective
cohort study a meta-analysis and a
systematic review suggests that moderate
egg consumption about an egg a day is
not associated with heart disease and
may actually reduce the risk in some
populations but here we've got some
carbs in the fruit we've got protein in
the yogurt and the eggs and a bit of fat
in the eggs as well plus lots of veggies
and i also love the kimchi action there
for those probiotics as well
now in this clip he calls out that his
fans would likely be shocked that he's
drinking of calories in a smoothie since
he apparently often talks about avoiding
liquid calories when you're on a cut but
it may actually be advantageous to have
the fruits and vegetables in this kind
of pre-digested form when you want to
prevent indigestion pre-workout so the
smoothie in this case does make sense to
me
but i will say that i know he's on a
cutting phase and sometimes athletes at
this level do need to be a bit more
specific on their macros
but i don't know how necessary it is to
weigh out your celery and cucumber
that seems
pretty intense to
me was so hungry i could not wait so
meal number two is some salmon with some
white rice i'm eating white rice with
some spinach and green beans 445
calories and 35 grams of protein okay so
for a post workout i would say this is a
textbook
balanced meal
we've got healthy fats and protein in
the salmon we got a good serving of
simple carbs in there to help replenish
those glycogen stores quickly and drive
that protein into the muscle
and we've got some green beans and some
greens for micronutrients and a little
extra fiber
now i assume that this was pre-prepped
before the gym because he seemed pretty
desperate to eat when he got home and i
do find that batch prepping like a big
pot of rice and a few fillets of fish
and a bunch of veggies at the start of
the week is a really great way to make
sure that you have something satisfying
in the house as soon as that hunger hits
but i do just want to note that contrary
to previous belief and he didn't say
anything about this but i'm just
mentioning it that the anabolic window
is not as narrow as we previously
thought so it's not absolutely essential
that we get that post-workout meal in
immediately for muscle growth unless
you're starving which it seems like he
might have been in this case you get a
little loopy when you're hungry
better better
[Applause]
so
get that food in
stat so i've actually tried to start
eating more variety of protein
throughout the day i usually just steps
like one or two types but now i'm like
really constantly changing it i love
that will switching up all of his
protein options because like i always
say variety is the spice of life it
seems like will is really making an
effort to not only pay attention to the
numbers for helping him meet his fitness
goals but also to diet quality for
general health also love that he's
working tofu into the usual rotation
especially since soy based products have
often been demonized in the fitness
community for their alleged feminizing
effects
but there's actually been a ton of
research done on the phytoestrogens
found in soy products and contrary to
what bro culture often suggests
they do not affect testosterone levels
despite their estrogen-like properties
so
kudos to will for helping put that
unfounded myth to bed
overnight oats one cup of cashew milk
one scoop of protein of your choice one
cup of oatmeal raw a little bit of fruit
175 grams of some coconut yogurt there
is 640 calories and have around half so
around 320.
this looks awesome and also inherently
very well balanced so we've got carbs in
the oats and fruit and a little bit of
protein in that yogurt and of course in
the protein powder now it is a little
low in fat so if this was my bowl of
oats i would probably want to add like
some nuts in there for the crunch factor
but i'm also not super surprised that
it's on the low fat side since again i
know that will is on a cut it's really
not uncommon in the fitness you need to
cut fat if anything is going to be cut
since fat is calorically dense and when
it comes to muscle protein synthesis
specifically
it's arguably the
less important macronutrient compared to
carbs and protein
of course not less so important for
general health but possibly less
important for specific fitness goals
i was very happy to see him have that
omega-3 rich fatty fish for meal 2 which
is kind of a rarity in the tilapia
obsessed fitness communities so i do
think that having a lower fat meal three
in this context
is totally fine before dinner is coming
down to the condo gym and running until
we burn 300 calories each cause
sometimes you come down you don't feel
great you just kind of want to walk it
out and you won't burn as many calories
so this just keeps things consistent
across the board okay so first of all i
like that he has an activity that he can
do with his girlfriend that they both
enjoy
i mean
i wish i could get my husband to step
foot in a gym
time
it's a game
but i digress as for the 300 calorie
goal i'm sure will is well aware of this
and he's kind of just using the 300
calorie counter on the treadmill as a
bit of an arbitrary goal post that he
could theoretically be manipulating up
or down as his trading regimen changes
but i just want to note that the calorie
expenditure counter on fitness equipment
is notoriously inaccurate ellipticals
are generally the most deceptive and
they've been shown to overestimate your
calories burned by about 130 calories in
30 minutes
and equipment like the stairmaster can
easily be hacked by leaning forward
which would significantly reduce the
calories burned basically one study
found that the stationary bike
overestimated by seven percent treadmill
by 13
stair climber by 12
and the elliptical by 42
honestly if you're using this data as
just like a benchmark as it sounds like
will is doing i don't think there's any
harm in that
but if you're using it to inform how
much you should eat which is kind of
what will did in one of his challenge
videos here which is more in line with
kind of like our calorie counting
ballerina situation
then it's very possible that you could
grossly overestimate your caloric needs
now if you want to make these number
outputs on these machines a little more
accurate
just make sure that you are inputting
your weights and any other demographics
it asks for and of course keep your
hands off the handlebars for the cardio
we both actually remove our apple
watches from our risk what because this
is in addition to our 10 000 steps that
we already do okay so i just want to
preface this by saying that i know
in will's situation that again he's on a
cut and often cardio comes with a
territory and i would be surprised if a
lot of his viewers are kind of in the
same boat and have the same goals but
just as a reminder to most of you
watching my video here
i just want to let everyone know that
you don't have to pile a 30-minute
sprint on top of getting in your 10 000
steps a day which fyi is an arbitrary
goal based on a marketing campaign in
1965
not legitimate science research actually
suggests that more modest increases in
step counts are also associated with
reduced risk of disease and better
health and again i know that will has
goals beyond just health but i'm just
sharing this for those of you who
already probably feel very overwhelmed
as for fitness trackers like smart
watches they are likely more accurate
than a piece of fitness equipment at
determining your calorie burn but a
recent meta-analysis of 60 studies found
that energy expenditure estimates vary
in accuracy depending on the activity
type and the product so one study found
that while apple watch was one of the
most accurate
a tracker like the pulse on could be off
by a whopping 93 percent
that's potentially hundreds of
miscounted calories so this is one of
the many reasons why i prefer to take
all of these external sources of data
with a pretty big grain of salt
the best tofu dish rusted potato bell
pepper and two garlic cloves whole
entire block of tofu you're gonna take
the block
i'm just here to break it up
we're adding some nutritional yeast
which is a very trendy cheese substitute
from a mashed avocado
this looks incredible
i love that we have lots of protein in
the tofu some carbs in the potato
healthy fats in the avocado and lots of
fiber rich veg
now the nutritional yeast also adds
about 16 grams of protein in a quarter
cup so
this is a very delicious
and high protein vegan meal now i'm
about to get way more technical than
needed for 99.9 of the population but
for most athletes we would ideally want
to see
four to five doses or meals of 0.25 to
0.4 grams of protein per kilogram of
body weight so based on my rough
estimation of will's weight which i'm
gonna peg at around 180 190 pounds
you're looking at ideally 20 to 35 grams
of protein per meal so this is still on
the larger side of what's optimal for
muscle protein synthesis
so he could theoretically spread this
into two meals with about three to four
hours between them for optimal
utilization but i also believe food and
eating should not run your life and if
you're constantly and unnaturally going
just from one meal to the next just to
support your gains
it leaves you very little room for other
fulfilling things in your life
also it's not like the extra protein
can't be digested or that it's a waste
as a lot of people say like it's still
going to contribute to satiety and
overall caloric intake so if this is the
portion that feels satisfying and
satiating to will to take him to that
last snack of the day
it looks really good to me final kind of
meal snack which is 200 grams of
watermelon and two
squares of some dark chocolate right
around 200 calories never get me to pick
watermelon for you like look at that
yeah
yeah that watermelon does
look like [ __ ]
but honestly what's up with this year of
crappy watermelons here in canada like
we had such a rainy spring i feel like
all the fruit has been kind of blah this
year but i'm really impressed that will
seem so blase about it because i feel
like a mealy plate of watermelon would
low keru in my day
but if it was a good melon i would say
that this absolutely sounds like a
delicious end to the day
obviously this is a very healthy dessert
and if satiety overnight is an issue for
will's cut
i would suggest maybe adding in a source
of protein or fat to really help him get
through that evening so maybe some
cottage cheese would be a really great
addition but will has pointed out that
he's really trying to move away from you
know a lot of artificially sweetened
foods and focus on whole foods that feel
good to him
so if this feels good and if the
theobromine and the caffeine and the
dark chocolate doesn't interfere with
his sleep quality
i say it sounds like a really great
choice to me
okay so according to both mine and
will's calculations
he's consuming just over 2500 calories
with about 30 from protein 50 from carbs
and 20 from fat so definitely this is a
higher protein lower fat diet
but probably what i would expect from a
fitness enthusiast on a cut
there really weren't any major nutrients
that i was particularly concerned about
and actually i feel like he's done a
really good job at covering his
micronutrient and his fiber needs even
when trying to lose weight and the fact
that he's consistently switching up his
protein carb fat and veggie sources
definitely means he's getting even
greater variety in his micronutrients
for the day
now before i really get into my thoughts
on his diet i want to reiterate and
remind everyone that
will has very specific training and
aesthetic goals
so my neutrality around his overt
calorie counting is trying to be mindful
and respectful of his body autonomy and
it really should not be taken as
universal support for this approach for
the general population
you know that this is not my style of
eating i actually think it can be
emotionally exhausting at best and
emotionally destructive at worst
but i also respect that some people can
just collect this data
meet their goals and move on with their
life now what i will say is that it does
seem that will has definitely evolved in
his approach to food in the past we've
definitely seen him adopt more of a if
it fits your macros kind of approach
where he's talked about having like a
daily tim hortons donut because he can
just kind of work the 220 calories into
his budget for the day he also would
lean more heavily on artificial
sweeteners and other locale diet
ingredients to kind of reimagine junk
food staples like a low calorie ice
cream or fried chicken whereas in this
video he actually makes it quite clear
that he's trying to move away from that
to try to focus on a simpler whole food
diet
i don't think that one approach is
necessarily better than the other i
really think it comes down to
what's going to feel physically better
to you
but also be more psychologically
satisfying
and while i do think that there could be
a middle ground here where you know
there's room for a mid-morning donut but
also for a watermelon and dark chocolate
dessert i think if this current approach
is physically feeling better to will
then it totally makes sense to me i will
however say that
even despite his training goals and
caloric budget
i do think he could stand to loosen the
reins like a little bit on weighing out
every single ingredient that he eats
like the calories in 40 grams versus 75
grams of cucumber
probably isn't going to wreck a prep
just saying what i really love most
about will is not just the overt sexual
innuendos spewed throughout his videos
that's what she said
don't you dare but that despite his
strict caloric budget
he still manages to prioritize variety
and keep mealtimes unique and
interesting
most dieters in his industry eat the
exact same thing every single day
partially at a convenience and partially
out of fear that maybe switching things
up would cause some major blip on the
scale
but getting in a nice variety of
different proteins and different produce
is not only really important for
nutrition status
but also for motivation and diet
adherence as well
as he discussed in his rest day video
here
he doesn't see health as strictly
physical well-being
but also as a complete state of mental
emotional and spiritual wellness
and i think that with age maturity and
just general data collection
he's probably getting better at finding
the most sustainable approach to meeting
his goals and enjoying his life
and on that note that is all that i have
for you guys today
if you liked it be sure to give it the
thumbs up
leave me a comment below to see who
you'd like seeing your view next
subscribe to the channel and i'll see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye